they are constructed with the utmost
Care by craftsmen who fully intend for
their Creations to be blasted to pieces
placed on the battlefield to look like
the real thing inviting attack from
enemy drones and missiles
that would mean they've worked Petro
tells us and will happily produce more
as many as needed
the operation of this Workshop which
remains fairly secretive is handled by
Mining and metals conglomerate met
invest having all these skills and
experience it's not hard to move from
still production to military decoys
made to order for Ukraine's military the
requests often change from one month to
the next as ever more sophisticated and
expensive equipment arrives from
overseas of which they make cheap copies
for instance the real M triple seven
Howitzer costs about two million dollars
but it costs about a thousand to make a
decoy
this radar system price tag 280 million
dollars a fake replica yours for two
thousand
these decoys are also far cheaper than
the weapons used to destroy them this is
the unit's trophy collection bits of
drones this from a russian-made Lancet
or an iranian-made Shaheed all very real
weapons that destroyed themselves
targeting very real looking fakes
as in previous Wars decoys have been
used extensively in Ukraine such as
inflatable ones like this
but the development of high definition
surveillance makes them far less
effective than these hand-crafted
alternatives
the enemy has many sophisticated drones
with better Optics and that capability
means we're constantly having to develop
before we would produce artillery just
from lengths of plastic but now we use
foam plastic to cover out intricate
details
ever finer skills required in the ever
more demanding craft of deception
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Central Ukraine
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera